pues empieza nuevamente al mediodía hora
de washington y los administradores
demócratas los representantes a la
cámara que ayer pues presentaron estas
evidencias tendrán nuevamente ocho horas
o solamente hoy podrán seguir
presentando las pruebas se espera que no
se tomen las 8 horas presentarán algunos
vídeos algunos argumentos adicionales y
después será el turno de la defensa de
donald trump
los abogados de don otro obtendrán
también dos días en total 16 horas para
defenderse para exponer su caso y
argumentar porque el trump no debería
ser hallado culpable de este impeachment
después vendrá entonces las preguntas 4
horas de preguntas después de eso
testigos si es que se citan y después la
votación final que según hemos leído y
hemos escuchado de miembros del congreso
podría cerrarse el 15 de febrero